hey guys I'm Abby sharp and welcome to
Abby's kitchen in today's what I ain't
youtuber a few I'm gonna be looking at
one of natalia taylor's videos now
natalia is a model and social-media
influencer with a huge subscriber base
Natalia's videos are typically based
around her own personal experiences in
like a story time style so her videos do
not stick to a singular theme but keep a
similar format of her sitting in front
of the camera and chatting now some of
her video topics ranged from zodiac size
to dressing up as Taylor Swift at
Disneyland I mean it's totally random
but it seems super genuine and authentic
and I think we can all really appreciate
that it actually looks like this is her
first wedding in a day so let's meet
Natalya making this video for quite some
time
simply because I am NOT a professional I
am also not a nutritionist or a
dietitian I am just me and I usually do
what is working for the current moment
so I guess as a recent I have been
taking my health a little bit more
seriously and I think I'm ready to share
that journey with you guys ok so I like
hearing Natalia's disclaimer here about
not being a nutrition professional and I
love the dietician shoutout
I also love that she likes to do what
works for her in the current moment
sounds super intuitive so I'm digging
that and it's also nice to see and hear
that she's really focusing on her health
so let's get into it but one more
disclaimer I know that these videos can
oftentimes be taken to the extreme I
want everyone out there to know although
I do like to keep my body in shape I am
a personal believer in instinctual
eating I'm not exactly sure if that's
the right term but basically eating what
your body feels like it needs to eat
because at the end of the day our bodies
know themselves best so don't take
everything that I'm saying in this video
too seriously or to constructively this
is just what's working for me right now
so far I really like this style of 180
day and I also love that she's gonna be
giving other examples of what she
typically eats to give us a better
picture of her diet
I am also super diggin Natalia's eating
philosophy I mean this is another
disclaimer that should be in all of what
a 2-day youtuber videos
while Natalia is showing her diet to her
audience it doesn't mean that it's
instinctual for her audience so I really
like that language I mean ultimately
think she's talking kind of about
intuitive eating but I love that she's
identifying it her own way I'm really
really hoping we can continue on this
vibe for the rest of the video so first
thing in the morning at 7:00 a.m. when I
wake up yes I do wake up that early I'm
normally not that hungry it's not until
later in the morning that I actually eat
something so first thing we go for a
glass of water because it's important
for jump-starting your metabolism I know
this jug of water is extremely extra we
keep this around the house because we
are always going through so much water
we refill it at Whole Foods and it's
just easy for us so bright and early
first thing in the morning this is the
first thing I'm gonna grab I love that
she said 7:00 a.m. is really super early
girl I have not slept into 7:00 a.m. in
over two years that would that's a pipe
dream for me right there but right off
the bat let's make something super super
clear while hydration is definitely key
and also a great habit to have first
thing in the morning a glass of water
does not kick start your metabolism
after a night of fasting the best way to
wake up your metabolism is to give your
body food or at the very least like some
liquid calories something water's not
gonna do it till around 8:30 that I
actually start feeling a little hungry
so for my breakfast I will prepare
myself a raw fruit and veg
plate and that includes various fruits
like strawberries and blueberries also
grapes are one of my favorites always
purchase organic if you can and avocado
avocados are truly my go-to when it
comes to eating and purely raw foods in
the morning I like having a full avocado
in the morning
because it helps me get in fact which we
shouldn't be afraid of fat in my opinion
as long as it's good fat so we have our
avocado right here something that I
really like to do is take some clover
sprouts just put them inside the little
avocado crevice I don't know it just
makes it more fun and it adds a little
more variety to your avocado in the
morning and then we'll add a good
serving of blueberries some fresh
strawberries as well I like strawberries
now the perks of eating raw veg in the
morning number one you are completely
detoxing your body number two you don't
have to worry about if you're eating too
much because honestly you can never get
enough fruits and veggies in your diet
so here is my fruit and avocado
breakfast plate Oh things have taken a
turn um where do I even start first of
all I really bothers me that she didn't
wash those those fruit that's for sure
and I love the colors in this breakfast
and it's no doubt nutritious it's
definitely not super balanced avocados
are great and fruit is also great but
these fruits are really high in fat and
sugar respectfully good fats and good
sugars yes but I would really like to
see some more protein or some higher
fiber whole grains to help balance
everything out now I know she mentioned
that she's raw until noon for some
reason but still this would be my
recommendation as a dietitian next
Natalia jumps into my favorite
nutritional buzzword of all time detox I
have said this time and time again but
apparently it's worth repeating foods do
not detox your body your body detox is
your body your liver kidneys skin lungs
they all work all day air day to detox
your body and while of course fruits
contain a rich amount of antioxidants
vitamins minerals and fiber and they're
amazing for our health
they don't magically get rid of toxins
in our body let's take a look at what
she's eating outside the home because
these are the bees
so basically a frozen blend of acai and
other fruits all together in this little
bowl with fruit topping and this also
does contain a granola which I know is
not fully raw vegan but that's just a
personal preference but these are one of
my go-to --hz when it comes to
convenient easy breakfast not to mention
they're kind of pretty
okay so acai bowls have become really
trendy over the last few years and I
agree with Natalia that they are super
pretty and a great option when you're on
the go sometimes these bowls however can
be pretty big and they don't really
contain much protein to keep you
satiated I'd actually say that this
particular one from Jamba Juice looks
like a perfect portion size and
according to the nutrition facts on
Jamba Juice's website this acai bowl has
a little bit of fat and a little bit of
protein but it's still mainly
carbohydrates over a hundred grams of
carbs to be exact now I want a flag that
I am NOT against carbs but a lot of the
carbs in these bowls are from quick
digesting carbs so from bananas honey
granola etc I would way rather see some
more veggies maybe some high-fiber whole
grains plus some protein and some
healthy fats in there for some satiety
we can go to our lifestyle app and start
plugging it in life some is a really
easy diet solution for anyone out there
that wants to track what they're eating
for me personally I think it's
convenient because I want to make sure
I'm taking in enough calories because of
my dietary restrictions if you're eating
mostly vegan especially raw vegan in the
mornings it's important that you're
getting all of the right things in your
body and you're not missing out on
anything you need but like some is more
than just a calorie tracking app they
also have recipes on here as well
personally I like the premium option
because you have way more features but
it's actually the easiest diet tracker
to use on the market in my personal
opinion ok so right off the bat you guys
know that I'm not a huge fan of calorie
tracking for most people but I do like
wine natalia taylor is using the app
with so many restrictions in her diet
like plant-based raw till noon not
eating after 9:00 p.m.
etc she states that she wants to make
sure that she's meeting all her
nutritional needs I like that she frames
this app as a tool to prevent deficiency
specifically for people that have unique
restrictions on the flipside I want to
reiterate that apps like these can
promote obsessive like tendencies for
individuals who are prone to or have a
history of disordered eating there are
lots of other ways to ensure that you're
meeting your nutritional needs that
don't need to be so time-consuming or
obsessive with numbers so for example
speaking to a dietician I personally
believe that intuitive eating or
instinctual eating as Natalia calls it
is putting complete trust in your body
and an app will honestly never be able
to replace that for some populations it
may be a good tool to use to help
understand your nutritional needs
however it should not be used as a
long-term crutch I'm pretty sure they
say people like me that snack throughout
the day are healthier is that true it's
healthier to snack throughout the day
instead of eating just three big meals
let me know if that's a fact but one of
my go-to is for a snack is watermelon I
get these little miniature watermelon
halves at full foods and they were
really easy fast snack all you have to
do is grab a spoon not to mention
watermelon is also like 99% water so
you're hydrating yourself in the process
type it into the life summon app and
we're good to go
love me some watermelon not only because
it is super delicious and juicy but it's
also a really good easy snack and while
watermelon is basically just sugar in
water I usually try to recommend a snack
that has a combination of fat protein
and high fiber carbs this not only
prevents huge sugar spikes but makes a
snack more satiating to keep you full
for longer honestly she's already had a
lot of fruit for breakfast so this seems
a bit like overkill another reason why I
just do not understand this whole raw
till noon situation a really easy meal
that you can make it home it is my
favorite fruit salad all you're gonna
need for this
each salad is fresh greens from your
local produce your favorite fruit of
choice sunflower kernels sliced almonds
and raisins
I feel like growing up I always hated
raisins but for some reason I'm trying
to get into that more so you'll take
your fresh greens and don't be shy you
can totally pile them on there just make
sure your hands are clean when you're
shopping for greens at your local
grocery store try to stay away from the
iceberg lettuce iceberg lettuce doesn't
really have very much nutrition at all
the darker green and your leaves are the
more nutrition you're gonna get I'm
pretty sure this is like a kale and
spinach blend take some raisins drizzle
those on top some organic sunflower
kernels we like to support cruelty free
sunflower farms I know that putting
seeds on a salad might seem a little
unexpected
I just think it's a better choice than
putting croutons on your salad because
you are steering away from unnecessary
carbs even though carbs aren't a bad
thing I like to get my crunch from
various nuts and seeds instead and then
you just add the fruit and there you go
that is something that I would normally
make at home for lunch and on top of
this salad you can just add a
vinaigrette if you would like or you can
leave a plain it's up to you but either
way a really easy recipe God come on
girl that is all have we not had enough
fruit I I love that she says to wash
your hands but then doesn't wash the
fruit again but honestly here my body is
begging for a little protein so
chickpeas healthy fats tofu knots eats
something more to bulk this up a little
I get she's got a little sprinkling
which she says is unconventional but
really I'd like to see more I would also
love to see her replace some of these
higher glycemic index fruits on her
salad with some slower burning carbs
like sweet potato or quinoa that's
really going to help her stay satisfied
a little longer because I know that they
have really awesome ingredients and
honestly they have great guacamole so
let's
through what I would normally order at
Chipotle so for rice it is always better
to get the brown rice because apparently
they bleach white rice and for beans I
like to get both options the black and
the pinto since i'm not going to be
getting any protein and then on top we
will put the corn salsa skipping the
cheese skipping the sour cream with a
little bit of lettuce sprinkled on top
now I like to get my guac on the side
that way we can add it on top of
everything so that is what I will
normally order at the Chipotle line okay
so let's talk about Chipotle cuz I think
it's a great option when you're looking
for you know something a little lighter
especially when you need to make a lot
of substitutions to make your dietary
needs you can kind of build your own
meal here and I really like this meal
much more so than anything else I've
seen because we've got the protein from
the beans we've got some fiber in the
brown rice we've got some healthy fats
in that guacamole and some veggies in
there as well a lot of fast food places
are high in sodium so if you're opting
to eat lunch out then ideally I would
make the effort to have the rest of your
meals and snacks at home just to balance
some of that sodium out all right let's
take a look at snacks I'm already ready
for dinner but I'm gonna reach for these
instead dal real makes these really
amazing coconut date rolls these things
are amazing they're composed of just
dates and coconut and I don't know why I
like to keep mine in the freezer it
makes them better somehow but they're
really sweet they kind of taste like
candy if you're a sweet tooth person
like me you need to try these out that
looks like a super delicious snack
honestly and with 3 p.m. rolls around I
am usually craving something sweet and
dates are an absolute favorite because
they're sweet they're naturally sweet
but they also contain some fiber having
said that in the context of Natalia's
day there's already been a lot of sugar
from fruit and not a whole lot else I
mean if she doesn't want to give up her
dates maybe I would suggest pairing it
with some more fat and protein babies
smear and some nut butter or stuff it
with some nut butter that might be a
better option versus just kind of having
a little bit of coconut on the dates
because this is when I get to have fun
my dietary restrictions definitely
loosen up towards the end of the day I
think this is probably the meal where I
get the majority of my carbs the
majority of my fat and I really get to
have fun and be lazy and maybe this is
just me but when I'm at home and I'm
getting ready for dinner I do not
usually feel like cooking anything too
extravagant most of the time I'm a
practical individual so I like to eat
vegan chicken tenders or buffalo wings
they're so easy to make you just throw
them in the oven and they cook and you
don't even have to put in it that much
work I'm pretty sure these are made out
of soy or some other ingredient that is
100% wheat free but I pair them with
some sweet potato fries I'm a huge
french fry person especially the waffle
fries but these are made out of sweet
potatoes which is just a healthier
alternative than regular potatoes but
take some of these throw them in the
oven and there's my dinner I don't
really understand the idea of saving all
your flexibility until the end of the
day doesn't really seem instinctual to
me but let's talk about Natalia's dinner
here so there's a lot of great
convenience foods out there that are
great when you're in a pinch and you
just need to get something on the table
super super fast you know on any
occasion but I wouldn't try to rely on
these options daily because like what we
talked about earlier when it came to a
lunch time these can be really high in
salt I did a rough calculation of the
amount of sodium in this meal and it's
approximately 870 milligrams of sodium
that's more than half of your
recommended sodium for the entire day so
this plus that Chipola meal would
definitely put you over the recommended
amount totally fine to do on occasion
but I wouldn't make a habit of it every
single day I'm surprised that her app is
not guiding her on this one also
I would have really liked to see
something green or some kind of
vegetable to pair with those chicken
nuggets and the sweet potato fries you
do not have the luxury of being home and
you are out and about biology is where
it's at my friend
even though I eat mostly plant-based
foods I would never be able to give up
pizza but lucky for me
biology is a great option for all of you
thing is out there and that are looking
for a pizza that's going to taste like a
pizza they actually have a vegan cheese
and crust option they use the diet
cheese which is a really popular
alternative and on top of that I just
put my favorite veggies like black
olives and much room along with a side
of buffalo sauce because buffalo sauce
is plant-based now obviously this is not
a selection I would make every night but
on occasion I still love to enjoy my
favorite foods like pizza and if I take
a look at my life some app it will let
me know how many calories I have left
for my daily intake which is a really
great way to reference what choices you
want to make for dinner because
sometimes I just need a little pizza mmm
well you know pizza is super delish and
of course any pizza looks awesome to me
I also love a good side of buffalo sauce
so I would crush that um and it's great
that this place offers vegan options as
well but again take-out foods like this
pizza from biology are totally awesome
in moderation but they are also high in
salt and low in veggies and protein
according to their website one slice of
her pizza has almost 400 milligrams of
sodium and let's be real you're gonna
have more than one slice so if you're
gonna be ordering pizza maybe try to
pair it with a side salad from home with
a simple oil and vinegar dressing that's
gonna help to balance out some of that
salt now that I have plugged in every
meal for today life some is informing me
that I have a few calories left to spend
so I have a little room for a sweet
treat if you're a chocolate fanatic
these are some of my favorites
chocolate snacks that you can enjoy for
yourself pork thins is one of my
favorite brands I personally prefer dark
chocolate because it doesn't have any
milk added to it or the unreal peanut
cause they taste just like Reese's Cups
only they don't have any animal products
in them and they're gluten free and
organic mmm this is when I have issues
with the calorie tracking app okay so
here Natalya is using the app to
determine if she's had enough caloric
room for pizza based on how many
calories she has left and also if she's
got room for dessert sorry girl but that
is the opposite of instinctual eating so
instead of taking a moment to check in
with yourself to learn how hungry you
truly are you're trying to get that
information from an app which is just
basing everything off of some simple
math there are so many factors that go
into your caloric needs your activity
your metabolism whether or not you
fidgeted today your unique gut
microflora an app you download for $3.75
a month cannot account for that also you
don't need an app to tell you that you
can have a treat these chocolates look
delicious and I've had both of them and
they are pretty good but I don't think I
would have an appetite for more sweet
things after having a full day of fruit
but you know I got it like chocolate is
pretty much his own food group so no
judgement here now let's take a look at
Natalia smackers for the day based on
her home meals this is a super rough
estimation because unlike other
youtubers and what eat in a day videos
that actually walk us through the day
she didn't really show us her portions
for things like dinner so he had to make
some assumptions on her part but let's
take a look anyway so based on the at
home recipes Natalia was consuming 1644
calories 41% of which is coming from fat
48% from carbs and 11% from protein
while I don't like to focus much on
calories I do believe that even with my
generous estimations of her meal
portions that our caloric intake is a
little low
when using a lot of these calorie
tracking apps you typically input your
height weight activity levels and
caloric goals like losing weight stay
the same gain weight etc and then they
spit out some general recommendations I
have no clue if she suggested weight
loss was her goal but I definitely think
she needs more food thinking of
nutritional needs because of her lower
caloric intake and it's
unclear if she takes any vitamins to
supplement her plant-based lifestyle she
may be missing out on really important
vitamins like vitamin D e b12 and folate
but let's talk about what I like about
Natalia's day first of all her
disclaimers at the beginning of this
video I was loving Natalia's disclaimers
about not being an expert and that her
diet is her own and may not work for
everyone
I also liked how she described her diet
as instinctual which is something that I
constantly preach on the channel even
though of course I use a different name
number two I love her tips for eating
out the reality is that many of us don't
have the time to cook at home every
single night and we end up of course
eating out luckily there are a ton of
great healthy fast food options and I
like the Natalia share some of her
favorite eats and even that she isn't
afraid to occasionally eat out it's
obviously a nice idea to cook all of
your meals from scratch at home but I
think we can all agree that this is just
not very realistic
now let's talk about some of the things
that I think Natalia can really improve
on I think she needs an increase in
calories and a little more balance in
her diet
I like how Natalia eats every few hours
however I do think her meals could use
some more substance and just some more
balance there's a lot of fruit going on
from the fruit plate the salad with the
fruit the date roll snack etc and I
don't see a whole lot of protein and any
meal other than maybe the at home dinner
this is partially the problem with the
whole raw till noon situation but my
recommendation would be to maybe have a
little tofu scramble for breakfast and
then instead of having whole avocado for
breakfast she could space out her fat
intake to add a little bit more balance
so we'd be having half an avocado for
breakfast the other half and her salad
at lunch and maybe adding in some pulses
or nuts this will help make sure that
all of her meals are a bit more
satiating prevent some of those blood
sugar spikes and also support any
exercise and activity she's got going on
in her day I would also love to see some
more vegetables in her day
I hope this comment is not like super
offensive but this diet kind of reminds
me of a typical picky toddler's diet
lots of fruit minimal veggies and
protein foods chicken nuggets and fries
for dinner and chocolate for a dessert
honestly I can't believe I'm gonna say
this but my 20 month old
it's a much wider variety of foods in
his day yes she got a tiny bit of
alfalfa spreads at breakfast and the
rest of our veggies really was coming in
at lunch time in her greens with a salad
but she was definitely missing out at
dinner
I'd love see smart snacks and a
breakfast and ultimately I know that
there's just so many other great hearty
vegetables that could really be
contributing so many important fibers
antioxidants and nutrients to her day
ultimately I really appreciate that
Antalya disclaims in the beginning that
she's not an expert whoever she is
making some pretty conflicting claims
without sharing any evidence to back it
up now I love that she has a disclaimer
that she's not a dietitian but I think
that right off the bat she is still
putting out some misleading information
starting the day with a glass of water
of course is a great way to stay
hydrated
however Natalia makes it clean that it
kick-starts your metabolism we've gone
over this folks fake news likewise
Natalia's claim that fresh fruit can
detox your body is also bunk
of course fiber it fruit is really
important for promoting bowel movements
which is in a sense a detox but it isn't
in itself detoxing your body is doing
the work and that brings me to my next
point
mixed messages I don't know about you
guys but I'm feeling confused I mean at
one point she calls her eating
instinctual but meanwhile she's
promoting using a calorie counting app
to give her the permission to have
chocolate or pizza then lists a bunch of
food rules one of which has absolutely
no evidence to back it up I just see
this as another real disconnect and
another example of influencers co-opting
intuitive eating messages without
actually understanding what they mean
I think Natalia has some really great
intentions and she offers some realistic
ideas for dining at home and eating out
but ultimately I felt her diet left a
lot to be desired I don't know about you
guys but I am feeling pretty hungry and
not just for fruit so if you liked this
video please do give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below with any other
youtubers that you want me to review
subscribe to the channel and I will see
you next time on Abby's kitchen
by